president biden trying to have it both
ways on record high gas prices
you see when prices rise it's the fault
of vladimir putin racist republicans and
greedy big oil companies
there's an impediment to production in
the united states
and it's called the bankers on wall
street putin's war is already hurting
american families at the gas pump
putin's price hike in gasoline the
consequence of putin's price high
republicans have offered plenty of blame
but not a single
solution but when prices drop it is
directly because of biden's genius mind
and masterful problem-solving abilities
the white house getting called out for
taking a victory lap on the 50-cent drop
in prices even though they're still at
record levels we have seen gas prices go
down
in in the past 34 straight days
i'll go down dollars a gallon higher
than when you guys took office though
for first of all we have to look at the
imp
how we got there right we you think
about the the war that russia has taken
on in ukraine
so at the biden oval office the buck
apparently doesn't stop there but if it
did hunter would probably give it to a
stripper
but now after coming home empty-handed
with no big oil deal from the saudis
biden is going all in on green energy
the white house says biden will take
additional climate actions this week and
mayor pete is pushing electric cars on
struggling americans
is the buying administration um
actively pursuing high energy prices in
order to force americans into electric
vehicles of course not the more pain we
are all experiencing from the high price
price of gas the more benefit there is
for those who can access electric
vehicles it's
wow is that for real
what he is like the more pain
that is because or did we cut it off
before he said i would never say that
like that is an amazing admission the
climate guy
alex who was on with neil cabuto this
afternoon i was able to hear all of it
because we get our hair done at that
time but earlier today he said something
like we have to speed the transition so
we don't want any more oil projects so
it's it's as if
the administration knows what it should
say but they can't help themselves
because they what they really want to do
is to
hasten this transition which would be
great if it was physically possible but
it's not and so they're not doing any
adaptation and the other thing that's
very strange it's like every
administration official is auditioning
for their future job as a car salesman
for the electric vehicle industry right
today uh you had another instance of
this and and also then i believe
tomorrow the reason they're doing all
this press today is the president is
going to declare an emergency on climate
change and declaring emergencies last
week on abortion care and declaring
emergencies about inflation well they
don't even care about inflation but the
emergency declaration is the way that
they are avoiding any sort of leadership
responsibility or legislation yeah you
know
jesse there are so many emergencies
as
while he's president
i mean wouldn't you not want to keep
saying there's a lot of emergencies
there's no emergency it's a political
emergency if there was a real emergency
joe would have put solar panels on both
of his homes in delaware you know
delaware doesn't have a single offshore
wind turbine not a single one and joe's
been running delaware for four decades
do you know delaware gets 92 percent of
all of its energy
from natural gas
isn't that beautiful the guy doesn't
even own an electric car
i'm a little worried they're trying to
put wind turbines off the coast of the
jersey shore i did a deep dive into it
dana okay
it's a dutch company so americans aren't
even going to get paid for it
energy prices are actually going to go
up after they install it the fishermen
are very upset because it's going to
destroy their fishing waters you don't
want to see mad fisherman and uh you can
see it from the coast so it's going to
ruin people's views so i'm going to have
to stage a protest
i might chain myself to the turbine i
might do a hunger strike i haven't
decided yet but i talked to my oil guy
today do you have an oil guy yes i do
all right i said oil guys
mine's not sven why why are the prices
at the pump going down he said there's
three reasons one u.s refineries went
full throttle hit 100 capacity two all
every summer after july fourth weekend
it goes down because demand goes down a
little bit and then also fears of a
recession all right but they're
predicting oil prices are going back up
so joe should not be patting himself on
the back if they see big earnings come
out in the next two weeks or a hurricane
hit the gulf that's going to send
prices sky high again then they're going
to they're going to blame
jesse's oil guy
that's right
yes the oil guys price hike i think you
should go for the hunger strike cause
you're getting a little uh pudgy down
thank you greg
yeah the bat the back surgery and
everything you've kind of let yourself
go oh my gosh yes do i do i really don't
i know you can rest your coffee cup on
it
do you find that i mean what do you make
of this blame credit turn around it's
their fault when it's bad it's my credit
when it's good which i i'd like to flip
that around if i i can greg because it
seems to me that if you get the blame
when the price goes up you should get
the credit when the price goes down i
mean that's is to me logical what is
illogical to me is that the federal
government is not leading by example
these electronic electric vehicles for
example why isn't the federal government
the largest consumer of vehicles in the
in the planet probably why aren't they
buying all electric vehicles for the
post office i think they are instead
they've just bought a whole bunch of
gasses
they do pilot projects just do it just
say from now on federal government only
buys electric vehicles but what if
they're so much more expensive than
other cars should the taxpayers pay for
that well i think that's an excellent
question i would suggest i submit
respectfully that if they want to lead
by example then they've got to bite the
bullet
okay this is what i think
i think when joe biden came out and he
told those mom-and-pop gas stations to
lower the prices and do it now they all
got scared of joe and they said we
better lower the price of gas look
that's all hogwash what this guy is
doing right now is he's taking credit
for something that he didn't do okay and
now they're if he declares this
emergency he's going to everybody's
going to say oh my gosh what are we
going to do there's not going to be any
gas and even though he's taking credit
for more gas uh
they they've got to buy now an electric
vehicle an electric vehicle the average
one
sixty four thousand dollars the average
car cost forty six thousand dollars the
average american doesn't have a new car
so the average american and when pete
buda judge says look you may pay a
little more on your car payment the
average american doesn't have a car
payment the average american is driving
a car that he or she has had for a long
time and they're not making payments the
car is paid for it's old they're just
surviving and deciding if they have
enough gas to go to work and to buy the
food that they need and the sad part of
all this is that they don't understand
america they don't understand what's
going on in america when they say oh
just buy an electric vehicle or oh the
government should should get electric
vehicles we don't have the
infrastructure for electric vehicles we
can and i'm not going to tell you who it
is but the guy that i buy some of my
cars from he says to me janine i'm
buying one he said i don't even like it
i don't want to drive it i can't drive
it anywhere but around town
this is all let me finish this is all
make-believe nonsense where america is
not supporting these green lunatics i
was driving it to work today went to
starbucks
charging 10 charging stations in the
starbucks yeah but it's growing the
infrastructure will work what if you're
an american living in middle america
who gives a damn about what's going on
in new york city next to the starbucks
you have to drive your you have to drive
an electric car back home that's to
prove it to us we had a clean place yes
you could stop every hundred miles
exactly
thank you
now i respect this argument beyond your
own car
like like what if somebody needs gas or
oil for other things well you know
you're a tractor yes a tractor
but also
what has happened in science
what has happened in science that would
lead you to need to declare an emergency
right well
it's july
and it's hot right but it's not like
something has changed it's not like
originally when we had the coven
restrictions initially that was an
emergency because you needed that right
now it's not an emergency on covid or on
uh electric vehicles dana it's a
political emergency it'll get us off of
the uh as long as you're angry
as you're angry and you're faking doing
legislation by declaring emergencies
maybe they'll see if they can get a pass
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now